الجيش الامريكي يبحث عن تزويد ترسانته
بصواريخ متوسطه المدى بعد انسحاب واشنطن
من معاهده الصواريخ قصيره ومتوسطه المدى
مع روسيا يتنافس في تصنيع هذا الصاروخ
شركه لوكيد مارتن الامريكيه وكذلك شركه
الصاروخ الجديد ستستخدمه الولايات المتحده
في مناطق المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وكذلك
سيكون صاروخ فائق الدقه وقد اطلق عليه اسم
ال ار ام
الجيش الالماني يعزز قدرته بمئه مركبه
مدرعه استراليه من طراز بوكسر مجهزه بمدفع
من عيار 30 ملم المدرعات الجديده ستحل محل
مدرعات ويزل تو والتي يستخدمها الجيش
الالماني من المقرر ان تتسلم برلين هذه
المركبات بحلول عام 2025 وبينما لم تكشف
عن قيمه هذه الصفقه اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الالمانيه انه سيتم تمويلها من الصندوق
الذي تم تخصيصه لتحديث الجيش الالماني بعد
الحرب في اوكرانيا والذي تصل قيمته الى
100 مليار
[موسيقى]
كوريا الجنوبيه اعلنت البدء في تطوير
مسيرات عموديه لنشرها على متن مدمرات كي
دي اكس المسيرات الجويه الجديده ستتمتع
بقدرات استطلاع متقدمه بالاضافه الى
مستشعرات كهرو بصريه وكذلك اخرى تعمل
بالاشعه تحت الحمراء هذا لضمان قدرتها على
العمل ليلا ونهارا وكذلك في ظروف الطقس
المختلفه حيث ستستخدم هذه المسيرات في
البحر الاصفر بالقرب من الجزر المتنازع
عليها بين الكوريتين البرنامج الجديد
سيتكلف 421 مليون دولار ومن المنتظر ان
تدخل اولى هذه المسيرات الى الخدمه بحلول
عام 2031